okay
we are here to talk about incremental
language development
and we've got a few functions we're
going to look at here
echo evaluation okay
so this is the new design another
iteration of this design is that correct
yes
um what am i seeing in notebook here is
this
it's the same thing it's just that we
were told that um
there were problems with with today's
builds so we prepared that
i see right okay we can't run in today's
builds okay
so what what is the so this is what it
looks like
so this is the ordinary
is that space really what what happens
when i say echo
oops
oh yeah that space isn't as big right
right how come it is is this big in this
mock-up
is that just a mistake or is that
something that what got changed is wrong
the design from billy billy here
that space is wrong okay should look
like this
okay
um
i mean this is kind of weird but i think
it's it's um
okay so these are the depths is that
right this is the depth
what is that what is the number there
that's the
the depth of that go evaluation
okay i think we should go go with this
so long as we fix that spacing problem
okay okay unless anybody objects to it
i think we should go with it i will
we'll see how we feel about it
it's something we can change later
make sense
notation for leap days and months and
new calendars
right so the thing here is that in some
calendars
there are days with the same number but
distinguished by the fact that ones are
are lit the others are not and so
oops the the
what we have seen in the main reference
we are using
is that they are distinguished by a
boolean but that means that most
days will have a number which is
something come up false oh gosh that's
crazy
all right i mean i understand this case
yeah
so for example this happens both for
months and four days so this is the
example for months this is a year in
which we have
uh 12 months but you see for example
that month
um seven is repeated
the first time it's called seven true
29 days the second time is seven falls
okay hold on hold on hold on hold on
so this repeated month exists for what
reason
yes so this is a lunisolar calendar and
because a month a lunar month is
shorter than um
30 days then there are years with 13
months
okay so what do they call these months
if somebody was writing out
i mean they don't say seven false right
they
they call it first something second
something
so they call it the first seven the
second seven
right and they will have uh some word i
mean in in in hindu i think they use a
word something like adika
and that means the second apparently
okay but if they're writing the date in
a document
now as we would write
you know whatever it is 9
9 20 or something for today
when they do that what do they write for
that seven
so the seven will have some name and
then
the the first the two or false will be
just the name of the month or the sec or
the month with something like second
for example this happens also in the
jewish calendar the adar month
and they use adar or darth too
okay do we have somebody who knows that
do we have if i have somebody here who
happens to know do we have anybody who
knows these these um
um i don't think so okay
let's see if we can find etai and sushma
as samples okay um
because what i want to know is for
computers they must have a way to do
this
and it's not seven true self and false
there must be you're filling out a form
there must be a way that those are
specified
see what i'm saying yes yes
so we were thinking of of having the
month seven the standard seven
that's the seven and then decorate
somehow the second seven with uh
well the question is whether it's a
string you know whether it goes to a
string
because right now okay in all calendars
i mean if we if we pick some random
okay question right now
these things are
numbers right hello
hi we have a cultural question for you
sushma
okay we have been told that in
what is it the hindu calendar
okay that occasionally there are second
month sevens added and things like that
are you aware of this what what do you
mean by second
month seven so there are months
whose different months with the same
name
it's just that these are the lunar
months right and one month
is uh yeah two consecutive names and i
think the
the second one is called adika something
like that
uh so i mean okay so there are uh
i should one second i'm not in the mode
of thinking this but there are two
different types of calendar one is based
on the hindu solar calendar and one is
based on hindu lunar calendar and the
months might be
a little different not too different but
um
like you know there is a day or two off
or something like that
um so
i know what you're talking about advica
but i'm not i
i don't have complete correct answer for
that though
but so when when people use these
calendars
do they do they have computerized forms
where you fill out
a a date from one of these calendars
what do you mean no it is generated
every year
and you can't know that before that year
starts
this is how it is okay but but i
understand that but when you
when you write a letter or something and
you date something or you write or
it's some you know there's some event
calendar somewhere and it lists a date
right what does it say
when it's the the secondary month seven
what does it say on the
on the um you know on the i mean
or or are these things used in a fairly
ceremonial way where things are written
out in words it's written
yeah it's mostly written out in words
and sometimes you know when
there are sometimes ambiguity which we
say it is like you know you can
celebrate anything in
both of these days or something happens
okay okay but but if you had to specify
this and you had to specify it in some
you know like like we would write you
know 9
9 20 for today right
if you were writing
the secondary month seven in a short way
is there a short way to write it
uh i don't know
so it already tells
usually we see this uh calendars right
so
we have this month right which is
equivalent to the
um months we have in the normal calendar
and then we have these names uh which is
like
uh uh like uh ashwini
it's names which is equivalent to dates
i i see it
um and uh it is not as
like the the dates are not as
consecutive
we would see like you know as it is in
numbers that it is not like just one two
three four
it does come one after other but
sometimes it might come
to like two days after the
so if it is like ashwini then it will
come
the second date might come two days
after because of the alignment or
something like that
that's how so wait a minute that that
word that you just used is that a day of
the week word or what is that word
it's it's it's uh day of like it's
equivalent to i i would say it is
equivalent to 1 2 3 4
like you know january 1st or january 2nd
something like that
okay so for example if you were to give
a sequence of i mean this just for our
cultural understanding
right is there a sequence of those words
like is there i mean what would they be
the sequential words that would be used
for this
uh i don't i i don't remember them
because i don't
but i do i think i do have a calendar
somewhere in my
uh house i can find it out and
uh get back to you guys as soon as
possible if not i'm
definitely sure uh my brother has one
because he follows them more than i do
so just give us a sense what what are
these things used for
um for for our festivals uh for
um yeah mostly very prominently used
to know when a festival falls on a day
um or something like that
um i know like in my family in general
we use
uh if we want to do any event on a
particular
month say then which months are
um uh acceptable months and which are
not
which day in the month is acceptable and
which are not so those kind of
things um they determine using
uh looking at those all right but so but
but i mean in terms of
look i mean the question here is we are
trying to
characterize so we're trying to convert
from
you know western calendar to hindu
calendar
the and the claim here being made is
that you can end up with
that there is a second month seven
sometimes
that is there because of the align
misalignment of lunar months
and that you can then end up you know
your date today for example might be in
the second month
seven and the question is how we
represent that
i see do you mind if i
uh come back to you probably in a day or
so
yeah that's fine okay so the answer is
it's not obvious
that's the that's the first question and
it sounds like we have to check with
some other people
i mean i i um
i think it gets much wilder than this i
think i was mentioning
you know uh christopher is trying to do
this work on some babylonian historical
thing
and there you know random months were
added
just by the edict of some king back you
know
2500 years ago and so on so
how are we going to deal with all of
this i mean the basic point is that
month names
all right yeah sushma i think that
that's that's probably everything that
we can get
from from you right now but yes let's
let um i guess it's nick and jose know
what you figure out okay that'd be great
thank you
yeah thanks thanks bye yeah so
in this case something can be done
because this is computed from the
position of the
of the sun and the moon so that's why
they compute it every
year because they are waiting to to know
exactly the data
but um but we have good good predictions
for that now of course the historical
data of what some king did
thousands of years ago that has to be
tabulated there is no other way
right i understand i understand
apparently i mean christopher was
looking at the thing for the
babylonian um
whatever it is apparently that is you
know it you get it from random scraps
of some random inscription says this or
that um
and occasionally the scholarship changes
and you have to that's an important
point for this historical stuff
occasionally the scholarship changes and
then you've got
you know this revision of you know it's
like the human genome
it's got a revision number effectively
um we do have the babylonian calendar
right nick
yeah yeah we have an astronomical
babylonian calendar so it doesn't have
tabulation from historical changes but
it has
somebody should send mail to christopher
and ask him about this because he is
literally just trying to
do i mean he has some quite elaborate
calendar thing that i think is is way
i mean again in these times right they
have these regular dates
which are based on you know the reign of
such and such a king
i mean don't don't they is isn't doesn't
japan still use something like that
yeah yeah the formal calendar in japan
still original
calendar um it
it basically follows a gregorian
calendar these days in the far past it
was a lunar calendar
um but it basically the year that it is
is like currently it's like i think hey
say
like 30 maybe it's like the 30th year of
the current emperor's reign
and whenever the emperor passes away
that's the last year of that rain
and it's the first year also of the next
person's reign so like 1999 was
the 84th year of showa and also the
first year of heisei
and they'd switch on january 4th or
something like that so you basically
have this big table of
when imperial rains end and you kind of
have an
error marker that says this is so and
so's reign and it's the nth year of it
all right so look one point about this
is
okay so there's there's more complicated
structures
than just a number is the basic point
the designation of a year or a month or
a day
can be more complicated than just a
number
so the question is what is that more
general structure
and i would argue that that we can do
better than the true false
thing and one question is
whether those things i mean we don't
want
to be pure strings you know we could say
7a
7b or something but i think that's not
very good we want it to be as computable
as possible
but okay so the basic point would be
okay so there's an argument that in
these cases we should have a full form
that is some kind of association that
says
you know like in the japanese case
you're describing it's an association
that says
emperor arrow and then that emperor
because who knows there might have been
two you know
you know there were how many people
named cleopatra who were you know
the you know queens in egypt who knows
i mean right so but we do have entities
for those people
so there's an argument that when we're
dealing with these these things
that what we do is we simply have an
association that says
you know emperor arrow and then we have
an actual
entity for that person and then whatever
it is you know
uh you know regular year arrow
17 or something right that we
go ahead i'm i'm not sure
what we have is a list of different
granularities that's fixed
and so i think what we need to do here
is that granularities are not
necessarily
identified by numbers we allow strings
in the original case in the geological
periods case
etc and in this case we need
a variation on numbers it's a small
variation because
we just need additional bit so perhaps
just by wrapping them with
leap the word leap or
no it's not going to be general enough
no i mean the thing the thing i'm
claiming is
once you go out of it's just a numbered
month and it's a numbered day
right i claim
that all bets are off it could get
arbitrarily complicated
you know but but it would still be the
numbering of a day it's just a very
weird number
yes i agree but what i'm proposing is
that that number
basically in its full form which could
be alighted
its full form becomes an association
that
for example in the case of regular
calendars literally gives
association name of emperor you know
i mean rather than trying to stuff it in
a list where we say list
you know emperor comma year comma you
know comma
integer for the year why am i suggesting
this
maybe i'm wrong maybe maybe each one of
these okay so there's two approaches
one is the point is it's somewhat
self-documenting
then what it means you know if you see
some random date
from you know ancient phoenicia
if we even have you know phoenician if
we even know enough about the
phoenicians to know that
um but let's say you know phoenician
date with
totally wacky things in it that we
are quite unfamiliar today right
we at least have a fighting chance of
representing those and for example
the whole thing about um you know
authority that is in in the case of you
know
in the case of babylonia right that
there are
you know you could say the authority
that says this is a date this what this
date is is so and so
and that maps into this but if we have
an association you can have all of that
information
right so i think a good place to put
additional information is calendar data
so for example the what we have right
now is calendar data for calendar
comma granularities will list the
different granularities
and for the japanese calendar the first
one could be
recognized error and the second year
the third month so there you
you see the meaning of all these
positional elements
oh boy okay so what you're suggesting is
i see what you're suggesting is that we
treat everything as mixed radix
basically yes with positional elements
i mean i i don't know does every
calendar okay so you're saying that
every calendar
worthy of the name calendar has this
notion of granularities that operate
like mixed radiuses
exactly it's just that the actual
identification of
of a day for example uh may be very
complicated the the
arctic and malian calendars changed
every day to numbers so we have to pair
those two numbers
in a pair and those two are the day
identification
but so then how do we tell given two
days in the aztec mayan calendar
how do we tell which one was after which
one
that might be a non-trivial test right
uh
correct i mean we would have to i mean
do subtraction of these uh
in the case of regular calendars we have
to go look in a table basically
exactly yes we still can do less
and that will figure out everything
right i mean we have to have right so
the
hour less than would then go and look up
properties of random kings of babylon
type thing
correct okay weird world
okay so
okay so what you're suggesting is you
say you don't believe in my idea
of of each of these elements becomes an
association you say
that we define positional we define
these positional elements
and then within each positional element
what happens we say
each one there has to be some other
aspect of calendar data
which gives essentially the the pattern
for what
those um uh
for what occurs at element such and such
of the um aztec calendar for example
is that right right so for example
imagine that we have somewhere grand
rally
whose duration is 200 days so calendar
data will know that and we'll be able to
report that
so calendar data is a place where we put
everything that's
that's known or needed to be known about
the calendar
okay but for example the cycle of the
whatever is the mayan calendar
which ended in whatever it was 2012 or
something i forget when
where it's the giant cycle ended um
but we can't you know right now we have
in
date object we have a specification for
um granularities right
um we're not going to document
here if we look at the granularities
right
century et cetera territory we're not
going to have some wacky thing in this
table
that says you know as mayan
long year whatever the long form wrap
around
time are we no we're not so here we have
the six basic granularities of the
gregorian calendar
plus extended notions of granularity
that are implementable in that in that
calendar too so what we will do is
document
all those other things in calendar data
so each calendar will have its own set
of generalities i say okay okay so you
can't ask for the
mayan long-form granularity of our
okay you have to convert to mayan
and then you have a mayan date object
and then you can ask
to add one are those in the units as
well
yep yeah so all of the mayan uh long
count steps
are in units so the mayan long count
calendar uses base 12
steps and they if you say i think like
there's a unit of mayan
tune is something on the order of
close to a year but again there's not a
mapping from
year to the mayan long count step
because it uses a different base value
gigafactor on our livestream was asking
is there any real use to supporting
these old calendars
you know it's it's history is valuable
like for example you know the 700 years
of astronomical observations made by the
babylonians
allows us to answer you know all kinds
of questions so long as we can know when
a particular observation was made
um and uh you know
in the theory that history is worth
remembering
it's worth getting right once and for
all you know
all of these calendar issues and then we
just don't have to think about it again
every random inscription found in
wherever that has a date on it we can
say when that actually was
um that that's the point brian is
mentioning the french revolutionary
calendar which i know had absolutely
crazy stuff in it
um although i don't think it was as
crazy as some of these other ones yeah
there's two versions of the french
revolutionary calendar too there's a
strictly
astronomical one and there's an
arithmetic
derivation of it and we have both
they're 10 day weeks and other things
like that
brilliant months or three weeks of 10
days
okay who invented that stuff anyway
it's probably somebody we've heard of
yeah it was a big secular push it was
that was the 10-day week motivation was
to move away from
a uh religious basis for the
oh that was viewed as a biblical seven
days or something
huh apparently people people didn't like
it because
they had to work nine days instead of
six
[Music]
yeah all right um
okay so anyway so so what you're
proposing we should we should get this
information from sushma and others
i recommend you ask christopher about
his babylonian
thing because i think that's again a
very very squiggly complicated case
but you're fundamentally saying that in
calendar data what we would record
is the list of what would it be so so
you're saying you would give a pattern
for what every date object would have in
it
that is it would have go ahead
sorry i i would say calendar data of the
name of the calendar comma granularities
so calendar data becomes
a property value
sorry entity value entity property sorry
table and so we have calendar data of
the calendar chromagnitis gives the list
of the
granularities for the
for identification of an instant even
okay so hold on hold on so so this
calendar data so calendar data
of mayan that's so well what does that
do
oh that's just giving what the heck is
that
can you explain nick yeah that's so the
this is the current version of calendar
data specifically set up for
holiday calendars um which is something
we talked in the last meeting about
changing because it basically lists the
schedules available
and so we're working with the alpha team
too on
on synchronizing that with alpha's
curation of holidays
and setting up a proper holiday
data or holiday calendar fine but this
is this is basically stock market
holidays and stuff like that
yeah so that's a list of exchanges and
defaults means national holidays
horrifying okay all right okay okay so
your proposal is
that this becomes what
so the entities will be the calendars
and then we will have
all sorts of properties about the
calendars okay when do they start they
can rarities
okay so the granularities will be what
will be a list of
of of the mixed radix granularities that
is for our calendar it would be year
month
day is that right hour minute second
okay so but then but that does not allow
so weak for example is not in here
exactly so do we distinguish what we
call the
granularities or native granularities
which are the ones you have to use
to actually represent a date
from the extended generalities where you
include everything weeks
millennia whatever so instant would not
occur here
this would just be our minute second
exactly
okay so these are base granularities
basically
that are used to actually define the
meaning of us of a moment
of of an instant and then there are the
what are we calling them extended or
something like that
granularities which are things like weak
which are simply
so those are not units because
these granularities could be something
which changes
changes time over over the course of
you know in other words it's not a fixed
it's not a unit
if i may if i'm am i correct about that
yes extended granularities will still
return a list of strings
then we have a separate property called
granularity quantities
or something like that that that gives
you an average quantity so you get an
idea of the size
okay our month everything
and if there is a unit that represents
that like we have the quantity years
then we return of course that one okay
okay so look i'm just not so for these
things here
what defines the structure of
so for example one of these base
granularities could be
you know regular period or something
whatever it's called is that right for
some other
is that is that right i mean yeah so if
if we use the japanese calendar as an
example again you typically talk about
eras so people talk about the heisei era
or the showa
era okay so era then would be the first
so in that calendar the first thing
would be era
and what tells us what kind of a thing
can be filled in there
is there a property of that calendar
that would tell us what the possible
values for era are
that's a good point we don't have that
yet but we could certainly right yeah
and we probably should have that for
these cases where it's a random list of
emperors or something
we probably should have the list of
emperors otherwise it's not clear how
you would get it
but we have another property called
granularity ranges so for example
for mnemonic cases we say month goes
from 1 to 31.
so we could have for strings we could
have some sort of enumeration
of support i think that would be a
decent idea
yeah i think so
um okay
wow yeah more cans of worms
time is complicated sandra has suggested
saying why don't we just number the days
one through 365.
people do have number day systems yeah
there are problems
too the problem is that there are
365.2481 am i remembering correctly two
six or something to four nine something
right days in the year and that
throws everything off um and that number
changes
as the earth's rotation period changes
as a result of random
uh you know activity in the mantle and
things
um
we actually have a an interesting
calendar which currently
is called rata die slating which is the
counting of days since january first of
the year one
so we are now about 790 000
days well but it's it's pretty common in
astronomy right the basilian years and
things like that which are
exactly in julian dates yeah right
relative to what there's a bunch
relative to january 0th
1900 and they're a bunch yeah but by the
way what do we do with the lack of a
year zero
so there's a parameter for it in
calendars
some calendars by default include a year
zero some do not
we made all of the calendars
parameterizable so if you want a
gregorian calendar that has a year zero
our default does not have one you can
basically specify that
as part of the calendar specification
right but by the way in your enumeration
thing
there is dependent enumeration right i
mean you might have
some weeks for example might have some
name
days but another week might not have the
same name days
so when you talk about an enumeration of
the value of some granularity
that presumably is the superset
enumeration
you see what i'm saying in other words
it could be that a higher granularity
constrains the enumeration of the lower
granularity
right if you haven't if a particular
year has an incomplete
month such and such month or no no such
such and such month
then if you listed out these are the
possible months
that would not be correct for some
particular year right yeah we definitely
want to go with the superset
right in generating them so it's the
same thing when we say
ranges of months we say 1 to 31 we don't
say oh it depends on the man
fine you know what in those ranges
are you oh gosh
i mean i think an enumeration is going
to be more useful but then you have
these things like
you know they're an infinite number of
years into the future type thing
so that's the only case that i can see
where you can't enumerate
like days of the year days of the
whatever those are all enumerable
the only one that isn't is years
right the first one typically is is
unbounded
because you have to consider the whole
access
yes yes so for those we are returning
minus affinity to plus infinity
as a range but then the other ones
but when you give a range does the range
necessarily is it
sort of uh you know densely in some
sense of integers filled
well in some sense it there are like for
seconds what do you give that you give 0
to 60
yes
how can it be to 59 can't you give
seconds in 59.972
or something how can it write that
0-59 for seconds
um yes sir you're right so for example
for
for months it's zero it is one to twelve
but for four seconds is zero to sixty
yes
you're correct okay but how do we know
which one is integers which one is real
numbers
that we don't mark yet we could
have a type so hold on a second in in
what we've done for coordinate systems
we've had this issue for coordinate
systems what are the possible values in
you know
parabolic cylindrical coordinates or
something
right how do we deal with it there
well in those cases it's always reals so
we just
enumerate the ranges we have a range
property
so i also go from zero to two pi and
things like that
and wherever possible we try and have a
normalization scheme
where you know if you say this is day
2.4 we can then normalize that down to a
number of hours minutes and seconds
where we can sort of we can standardize
that a day value on a gregorian calendar
will always be
an integer value and if there's a
fractional remainder then it gets
populated to hours minutes of seconds as
necessary
right in the same way i could say the
31st
month of this year we'll say well that's
you know
so many months after december
and so we increased the year value by
three and then continue running on
or two all right this is a complicated
kind of worms
but so what's the it seems like
we need to have a more complete story of
how this is all going to work we can't
answer the specific question on its own
okay all right quick quick look at some
of these other things
yeah so next we have three functions you
suggested
and
is this function interesting
for you since thing dust might
i mean it i think it could be
interesting
i see that's its primary use
does it raise to the level of i mean
the problem is that it suggests it's so
much
about mod and you know modular
arithmetic which it is not
or polynomial algebra which also it is
not
but essentially it's a bi wrapper it
turns
same test into a buy test is that
correct
i think so some sort of sem test buy
right
well that's an alternative approach as
to is to put an option
same test by
well we would need say same test is
is what says whether we want equal or
same q
it is that we want to intercept that
with an
additional function we use same test in
a few of
other places and ways you
i mean the typical thing one would do
now is to incorporate the f
into the same test explicitly
right but the problem is that the same
test is a binary operator
right i mean the issue is it's the
difference between sort
which takes a binary you know function p
which takes x and y here right and sort
by
which takes a unary valuation function
right right
and same test currently
wherever we use same test it is
expecting a binary
test function and so this is something
which goes from
a binary test function
you know which we can put in place of
the binary test function
to turn it into a buy function
yeah all i'm saying is with elaborate
coding one can use same test
already obviously you shouldn't have
this
right obviously i mean obviously you can
just write same test is
is um uh
you know same q uh
f of hash one f of two
yeah which is you know people sometimes
do
right i mean this is more of a
conceptual thing
and i mean the alternative approach
would be to have a same test buy
option what functions have same test
option
intersection are some there may be
others
um i'm not sure
right but i mean we don't have a union
buy
function right nor do we particularly
want one
no we don't but this is an attempt to
generalize that situation but we do have
a same test
um
i mean what would the moon
same by i don't know
to me the problem here is that we still
need to specify same q
so we still need the two arguments so
this would work like same test
goes to modulo equivalent
uh f comma thank you
yeah it's not really helping much
yeah it's yeah it's same size of what
you wrote
well let's try putting something with as
good a name as we can to the function
repository
and then we'll be reviewing it later
now this seems useful d trend delete a
linear trend
and possibly it could be generalized to
fancier trends
um no argument there but i'd like to
push back
a little on it being an ild function
well i admit that the statistics team
could be the one to do this
i think they should be the reason is
they're more likely to get it right fine
talk to them about it okay
i'm willing to guess that there are
several options and
default settings and tuning things that
go in oh i agree completely about
outliers and all that kind of stuff i
just think it's a useful function to
have
i mean it's it's so unquestionably
fine yeah i think it goes along
standardized for example things like
that yes
i agree who wrote standardized was it
the machine learning team
um
i think it was
that might go all the way back to anton
antonov or rescale might i'm not sure
this one is class is surprisingly old
standardized
okay um all right in any case
go talk to those people figure out what
can be done
okay actually gigafactory is asking the
reasonable question how many calendars
do we support right now can we display
today's date in every calendar
do we have a way to do that uh we
can current in in 12
2 currently there are only four
calendars um
right now in the branch that we're
polishing up for twelve
two they're 40. okay so there's lots of
get much more interesting
yeah there's lots of possible
permutations from there too of
you know their their different uh
astronomical baha'i calendars
depending on where your reference
location is which is a parameter so
there's
okay yeah okay so we can't do anything
exciting with that yet
um steve is asking is there a reason why
we always use the system clock and we do
not independently pull from ntp
i think we try to rely on the fact that
we're correcting for speed of light
by or for transmission times which i
assume the system clock
i don't even know how that works now
that i think about it when you
synchronize your system clock from the
nntp server
does it correct for your ping time to
the nntp server
that i don't know but i would expect
that it's the responsibility of the
computer to do those things not not us
no i agree i agree but the question is
do we have a way
it will be interesting if we had a way
to query the nntp server to ask what it
thinks the time is
um
what is that thing called the what is
that thing the thing that's in colorado
somewhere
the um
right so i mean this this fine thing
it's pretty scary that that tim yeah
anyway um
uh so you're saying that the computer is
not doing this so for example when there
is a
a leap second are not the computers
getting informed via this yes i think
they are because there's a demon running
your computer
that i think is querying this thing
exactly
yeah i think that stuff is generally
pretty well scheduled by
operating system developers
where it knows in advance when a leap
second is coming in
because right it's agreed in advance
right now and they're you know there's
some place you know like
you know play places like google tend to
do
things with leap seconds like smearing
them across a day where there's a
fractional
increase in time spread throughout the
day rather than dealing with the leap
second at once but
generally we rely on the operating
system for
for that sort of time keeping um but
there are other factors like
how you handle leap seconds when there's
different time systems which is
something that we've been discussing in
some detail for
future development and it's probably not
something jose wants to go into right
now right but
there's there's a lot involved right
no i mean we know that for the astronomy
stuff it matters
many many details of this matter it's
somehow a little bit scary that at the
end of the
you know how does one know time on the
internet at the end of it there's a a
what is that a bear with a with a
birthday cake
any top hat i don't know
oh yes it may be a hat oh yes yes it is
it's a
it's a clown bear with a hat or
something no i i don't know what this is
i'm not culturally aware all right let's
very quickly let's look at these other
things
pattern form
what is this yes the idea of this is
imagine you have a pattern imagine you
have something
where whenever you match
this okay let's say it's this
something like that that means you're
looking for something which matches
blank blank
but for purposes of the pattern binding
system treat that as 78
i see what in honk all are you saying
i'm saying if i say
f of this right
colon equals x squared
then i'm saying that f of a
a would now turn into
um the x would bind to 78.
is that crazy
only if you want it implemented
so this is the sort of thing we would do
with if much q do this
exactly yes right it's a way of cleaning
that up
i don't think it's so stupid and i also
don't think it's that horrendous to
implement
because as far as the pattern matcher is
concerned it just looks like blank blank
what this is doing is simply it's giving
you it's it's starting to fill the
pattern
um okay so so then you might ask this
question okay so then it gets a little
wilder if you say something like this
right
does that do now if you say f of
x colon blank blank
comma x blank colony
equals let's say x here okay
now i say f of 3 3
comma you know
i need the same one right
so that matches but
this
and this will match as well but
this no as soon as as you change
something it doesn't match
so the double x is required right right
i know it has
it has to be both the same thing so but
if this was three four
five even though the x's are the same
one of those x's doesn't bind and so it
doesn't match
so in this case here this would only
match
if the x blank here if i fed in f
of 78
no that's not no it would be f of a
a comma 78
right then it would match
i don't think this is a stupid construct
and by the way another class of
constructs we need to start talking
about are the two-way pattern rule
constructs
because as we get more and more into
theorem proving and into
all these systems where we can have
basically patterns on both sides of the
expression
which is what we've implicitly done for
years
in um i mean this is this is relevant to
axiomatic theory
and it's relevant it's relevant to
turning axiomatic theory into pattern
variables
but it involves patterns on both sides
of an expression
it's something as i say algebraically
we've done that for years when we say
you know with some random
polynomial equals some other random
polynomial the x's on the two sides
are effectively pattern variables that
we're then for example solving for
so we have discussed two-way rule with
two literals but
with patterns but we haven't discussed
it yeah
i i will raise a
um philosophical and a practical
objection
philosophically this is a more
restricted world and and
probably belongs in one as a different
sort of area functionality the practical
matter is our pattern matching code
is um difficult to
build on top of it it just is it's
hard to modularize i think ivan made a
pretty good faith effort but
yeah you've got stuff that has to deal
with uh compiled functionality
versus or packaging i know look i i
wrote the original pattern maturance
and sadly much of that code is still
there
well unsadly much of it isn't
um did i not say that politely
but um the fact is it is still not the
most
modular code i know it's complicated but
it is it just gives us a multiple
maintenance problem
no i understand it's complicated and it
was i mean the the good news about it is
that it was
it is code that makes many judgment
calls breaks into many many cases
um and that's the good news because that
allows for a lot of optimization the bad
news is
those those things are not particularly
modular
right and and there is a multiplicity of
terms of maintenance because of all the
cases
and if we try to put another structure
on top of that one that i understand
look i i think it i think it needs to be
rewritten
i mean at some point and perhaps the the
only thing to understand is
what is the value to doing that
rewriting part of the value is
that you know if we have an inventory of
new constructs that we can put in that
have
you know that are powerful that's a
motivation to do the rewrite
well but again i'm not convinced that
this belongs
in that world it's just not as
it it's sort of more focused it's it's
more general
what's symbolic algebra are we talking
i'm sorry we're talking about the
two-way rules
we're not talking about rules okay
yes i i agree i'm not sure it belongs in
that world either
i mean it could be right there's things
like pattern unification
that are needed there um
you know a good example my new function
find replace path that
given a set of rules and given a
starting point an ending point
it will tell you what the shortest path
by using those rules to get from the
starting point to the ending point
is right now if those are one-way rules
well and good but one can imagine
perfectly interesting cases
to do with axiomatic theories and things
where those are two-way rules
but to wear rules with with literals are
just
equivalent of a goes to b goes to a
which is very very nice not if your
notation for shrubbing
sort of buttons use this property you're
talking about where you have to go
backwards
in some places what are you saying
you're talking about something like a
hysteresis property i think where you
have to go backwards
in order to get from a to b you have to
use both directions well
maybe but i mean i'm not sure you have
to use both directions but it's
convenient to enter
these rules in a two-way form with
pattern variables on both sides in other
words this is equivalent to saying
let's say that this says g of x blank x
blank
okay we could enter that and possibly
this is the way to do it
f of x blank goes to g of x x
together with the rule um you know
g of x blank x blank i'm just saying
that syntactically
and practically this isn't the best
thing and there are things you can do
i think with two-way rules particularly
with patent unification that you cannot
do with
one-way rules but here we see
immediately that the first thing we need
is a way of going
from an expression that has patterns to
an expression that doesn't have them
and there we will find the questions of
what do we do with conditions
with modules all those those things
yeah right so a good example is this
recent work on their exists in axiomatic
systems
where there exists when it is on the
right hand side
becomes a module yeah i mean
this requires more thought no question
this requires more thought
um
yeah i i i think this could perhaps be
implemented using
pattern matching but i don't see it as
part of the pattern matching world
itself you're probably right
you're probably right wised and highly
sophisticated
well you're highly right you're right so
long as the methods
that are essentially automated theorem
proving methods don't end up in forming
the pattern matcher in some way which i
don't know for certain that they do not
don't don't end up what informing how
the pattern matcher works
that is that you know adding some
completion or something
is a way to speed up the pattern matcher
i don't know that for sure
i haven't thought about it enough to
know there might be special
there might be special cases where it
can right
but i mean the parameter is a story of
special cases
you know the specification of getting an
implementation is
quite special this um axiom
and theorem proving stuff is uh and
nuthbendix type completion i think is
intrinsically
um sort of like dynamic programming
backtracking etc
unavoidably so and so i don't think it's
going to
in general give any improvement on the
pattern matcher
except when it has to do backtracking
well the pattern matches doing that
already
the only thing this might be have an
advantage with is doing it better
that's what i mean right okay that's
what i mean
um because the pattern matcher does it
you know with or without not completely
stupidly but
in the case where it has dramatic
backtracking to do
it's not you know it's using
comparatively straightforward algorithms
to do that
yes i think though what you're you're
you're opening a pretty big
can of snakelets sniglets
um because that it's like with almost
anything that we overhaul
when you start digging into it you find
that the new code invariably has weak
spots also
sure and it's going to i'm not saying it
shouldn't be done
i'm saying no no it's a big project no
question it's a big project
but i think what we need to do is start
collecting things like pattern form
that are things that we should consider
adding the pattern matcher
you know that essentially justify
thinking about an overhaul
and the two-way rules unification you
know
completions etc
okay just a very quick and then we need
to wrap here
um yeah there's a lot of good things
here
a lot of good things although birds say
as it is is not going to make it as a
system function
no we we um specifically said that that
would be
uh no
you know this this what is it called
cockapoo or something
creature that's um um
so yeah danny do you remember the
criterion to sort this list
so these are the 20 best functions in
summary
these were um 20 culled from the top
the 50 most downloaded as best i recall
well some of these uh some oh
and many we're not we are not proposing
as standalone functions but as possible
um features well options or
or additions to existing
import pgn would simply be a a new
uh flavor for import yeah
for example all right okay let's let's
we're not going to get to this today
obviously
this one really does seem very
worthwhile this one is
is like some version of this really does
seem worthwhile
but perhaps this is purely automatic in
map and other functions
that this just happens if they've been
taking a while
that would be my preference and i i mean
the progress monitoring
framework which we are planning for 12-2
is the first step in doing these things
although it is not being brought in
automatically
and functions like map well i mean what
what we're proposing here is that the
person or person's working on that
at least have a look at these um wfr
functions
to see whether they fit in
whether maybe there should be a second
yes
framework for explicit cases
dynamic map etc we we're not really sure
okay fine we'll make sure they get that
then
um who are they by the way uh that'd be
me
and etai and julio
i'm sorry who was speaking uh devin
devin okay thanks
okay all right thanks a lot guys all
right gotta go
um and i think we're doing another live
stream in the top of the next hour
so see you all there thanks for